die Welt sie ordnet sich neu auf gleich
drei Gipfeln wollte der Westen klar
Position beziehen mehr Verbündete mehr
Einigkeit mehr Geld mehr Waffen mehr
Soldaten auch aus Deutschland 15.000 für
die neue eingreifttruppe der NATO das
alles soll Putin beeindrucken und diesen
Krieg beenden wird es das wenn Russland
in der Ukraine immer mehr Truppen
aufbietet die Sanktionen aussetzt sich
neue Absatzmärkte und Freunde sucht wie
lange hält der Westen durch und wie ist
sie zu lösen diese wahrscheinlich größte
Krise seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg wir
müssen reden mit diesen Gästen
Nato-Generalsekretär Jens Stoltenberg
und mit nuripur Vorsitzender von Bündnis
90 die Grünen
der Vorsitzende der Europäischen
Volkspartei Manfred Weber
Stefanie Babst ehemalige Leiterin des
NATO Planungsstabes
die Politologin Nicole deitelhoff
und der Journalist und Moderator Klaus
Kleber
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit
Illner
und sie begrüßt alle Gäste dieser
Sendung sehr herzlich zwei Tage
NATO-Gipfel in Madrid das waren ganz
kurz die Ergebnisse
der Paukenschlag von Madrid die NATO
verstärkt ihre schnelle Eingreiftruppe
von 40.000 auf 300.000 Soldaten
Deutschland will zusätzlich 15.000
Soldaten dafür aufbringen
60 Flugzeuge und 20 Marineschiffe
und die USA richten dauerhaft eine
Militärbasis in Polen ein
[Musik]
Klaus Kleber ist uns zugeschaltet aus
Hamburg
Journalistenkollege Moderator
Dokumentarist und lange aus Washington
von Dent berichtend für damals noch die
ARD wir sind Klaus Kleber in welcher
Situation in der Welt angekommen ist das
vergleichbar mit den 70er Jahren dem
Kalten Krieg damals
es ist schon anders wir haben eine
völlig andere Situation deswegen weil es
eben kein kalter Krieg ist sondern ein
in Europa stattfindender heißer Krieg
und wir haben es mit einer Situation zu
tun in der das westliche Bündnis jetzt
irgendwie sehr eindrucksvolle Gipfel
hingelegt hat aber meine große Sorge ist
die Existenz der Demokratie in den USA
die Zukunft dieser Führungsmacht die
internen zerstritten ist die nur zögernd
unter einem Joe Biden zurückgefunden hat
in eine leitende Rolle in der
sogenannten westlichen Wertegemeinschaft
das ist alles sehr brüchig im Moment
brüchiger als es damals war
und genau auf diese amerikanische
Regierung sind wir im Moment wahnsinnig
angewiesen Stefanie Babst ist bei uns
ehemalige Leiterin des NATO
Planungsstabes noch bis in das vorletzte
Jahr Frau Babst wenn sie auf die
Ergebnisse dieses NATO-Gipfels schauen
ist das so ein Epochenbruch ist das so
ein Paradigmenwechsel eben weil es eine
völlig neue Strategie gibt 300.000
Soldaten Eingreiftruppe Putin Russland
der klare Feind also von einem
Epochenwechsel würde ich ganz sicherlich
nicht reden ich habe ja den Eindruck
dass ich die Staats- und Regierungschefs
jetzt auch in Madrid sich in so einen
kleinen Euphorie Rausch so hinein
begeben haben also ganz begeistert auch
sind von den eigenen Beschlüssen aber
wenn man genau hinschaut was haben sie
für Beschlüsse getroffen dann ist es die
zu erwartende Verstärkung ihrer
abschreckungs- und
Verteidigungsfähigkeit das ist gut und
das ist richtig aber für mich wäre es
viel wichtiger gewesen wenn die NATO
auch Entscheidungen getroffen hätte um
klar zu machen wie sie eigentlich die
strategischpolitische und militärische
Dynamik in Europa zu ihren Gunsten in
Zukunft beeinflussen will das heißt
Putin zurückdrängen will und da habe ich
immer dritt nicht viele Antworten darauf
gehört wir haben und das ist interessant
dass sie sagen nach dem Ende des Gipfels
mit dem Nato-Generalsekretär sprechen
können und die Antworten auf sie fragen
hören sie jetzt
in Madrid begrüße ich nun den
Nato-Generalsekretär Jens Stoltenberg
guten Abend
300.000 Soldaten unter Waffen die USA
nun permanent wieder in Europa sind wir
in einer Art kaltem Krieg 2.0 fällt ein
neuer eiserner Vorhang wir befinden uns
in einer gefährlicheren Welt meiner Welt
in der es einen heißen Krieg in Europa
gibt nämlich Präsident Putins brutaler
Einmarsch in einen souveränen
unabhängigen Staat und genau deswegen
haben die Verbündeten der NATO die
Unterstützung noch erhöht um
sicherzustellen dass die Ukraine sich
selbst verteidigen kann das ist ja auch
Bestandteil der un-kater wir müssen aber
auch sicherstellen dass es nicht zu
einer Eskalation kommt hin zu einem
größeren Krieg der über dieses Gebiet
hinausgeht zwischen Russland und der
NATO weil das noch mehr Zerstörung und
Tod bedeuten würde die Nato hat zwei
Ziele die Unterstützung der Ukraine und
die Veränderung einer Eskalation
über 1000 Mann für die schnelle
Eingreiftruppe ich frage noch mal nach
denken sie dass ihre Mitglieder das
überhaupt leisten können bis 2025 ihr
ist absolut
also uns auf eine neue Truppe geeinigt
haben das heißt wir werden mehr Truppen
in hoher Alarmbereitschaft haben wir
werden auch mehr vorab stationiertes
Militärgerät haben und wir haben diese
vorbereiteten Truppen die schnell
eingesetzt werden können sollte das
notwendig sein
in Deutschland führt ihr vorbildlich
weil Deutschland gesagt hat das ist eine
besondere Brigade stellen wird um auch
das Baltikum zu verteidigen
das sind weitere Truppen in Litauen
zusätzlich zu denen die es schon gab das
ist unsere Vereinbarung unter den
Verbündeten wir sind daher gut
aufgestellt um diese getroffenen
Entscheidungen auch umzusetzen
sie haben gesagt Herr Stoltenberg die
Ukraine kann diesen Krieg gewinnen jetzt
sind stand heute mindestens 20 Prozent
des ukrainischen Staatsgebietes in
russischer Hand waren auch sie zu
optimistisch was wir jetzt in der
Ukraine erleben ist eine sehr
gefährliche und besorgniserregende
Situation
sie sehen leiden wir sehen tot wir sehen
getötete Zivilisten wir sehen die
Bombardierung von Schulen und
Krankenhäusern
das ist der Grund warum die Verbündeten
der NATO jetzt wesentlich Unterstützung
leisten für die Ukraine aber es sind
natürlich die Ukraine die jetzt den
höchsten Preis zahlen müssen und das
geschieht gerade auch an der Front wir
müssen also noch mehr leisten mehr tun
um die Ukraine zu unterstützen Kriege
sind immer unberechenbar aber es ist
unsere Pflicht unsere Verantwortung die
Ukraine zu unterstützen unabhängig von
den Beschlüssen der NATO am gestrigen
und heutigen Tage fordert der Präsident
der Ukraine weiter mehr Waffen und viel
schneller mehr Waffen besteht die Gefahr
Herr Stoltenberg dass die Ukraine diesen
Krieg machen kann so wie ich das sehe
und ich verstehe die Sorgen und rufe
auch von Präsident selensky die im
Rahmen des Gipfels äußerste das ist auch
die Botschaft dieses Gipfels nämlich
dass wir mehr tun müssen die Verbündeten
der NATO haben die Ukraine schon seit
vielen Jahren unterstützt die
Bündnispartner haben zehntausende
Soldaten trainiert und das begann
bereits 2014 nach dem Einmarsch im
Februar haben wir die Unterstützung noch
erhöht und unsere Botschaft ist es dass
wir immer noch mehr leisten können und
müssen um sicherzustellen dass die
Ausrüstung auch geliefert wird und
schnell zusätzlich müssen wir auf lange
Sicht planen das ist die wesentliche
Botschaft dieses Gipfels die Sorge von
würde mir selensky ist dass diese Krieg
sich in den Winter hineinziehen könnte
deshalb auch sein Drängen
muss es mehr Lieferungen von schwerem
Gerät auch von Panzern geben Herr
Stoltenberg muss beispielsweise Spanien
tatsächlich den Leopard 2 in die Ukraine
liefern ist das ein guter Gedanke
ja das ist eine gute Idee mehr schwere
Waffen zur Verfügung zu stellen auch
mehr moderne Waffen die den NATO
Standards entsprechen die NATO wird auch
helfen beim Übergang von den alten
Gerätschaften der Sowjet Zeit zu den
modernen natowaffen
darüber hinaus gibt es eine
Unterstützungsgruppe unter der
Schirmherrschaft der USA die die ganzen
Kapazitäten und Fähigkeiten koordiniert
es gibt ja die Anforderung der Ukraine
auf der einen Seite und wir sehen was
die Verbündeten liefern können aber die
allgemeine Botschaft ist mehr schwere
Waffen modernere Ausrüstung die
schneller geliefert werden muss das ist
die Hauptbotschaft
nun kommen die westlichen Waffen in der
Ukraine an aber eben noch keine
Kampfpanzer auch die USA halten sich
zurück der Bradley ist auch noch nicht
in der Ukraine noch mal die Frage
sollten auch Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine
geliefert werden aber die Bündnispartner
liefern ja bereits sehr viele artiller
Panzer Fahrzeuge
Schützenpanzer
unterschiedlichster Art
weapons die NATO trifft aber keine
Entscheidung über spezifische
Waffengattungen wir kümmern uns um eine
sehr enge Koordinierung in der
ramsteingruppe der USA wo die
Verbündeten und die Partner der NATO
sich zusammentun und zu sehen welche
Kapazitäten zur Verfügung gestellt
werden
die Botschaft dieses Gipfels ist dass
wir eine Entscheidung getroffen haben
zur Bereitschaft und der Struktur der
NATO um die Ukraine zu unterstützen die
Naht ist dadurch stärker und größer
geworden und ist bereit mit den
Herausforderungen der Zukunft umzugehen
was wäre Herr Stoltenberg in ihren Augen
ein Sieg für die Ukraine ist es der
Status quo ante
23.22 oder sollte der Westen sollte die
NATO um mehr kämpf
wir sollten mehr tun
mehr Unterstützung für die Ukraine
bieten mehr Ausrüstung mehr finanzielle
wirtschaftliche und militärische Hilfe
und dafür haben wir einen entsprechendes
Paket beim Nato-Gipfel verabschiedet die
NATO Verbündeten liefern ja auch
unterschiedlichste Hilfe und
Unterstützung wie zum Beispiel
Langstrecken artilleriesysteme
unterschiedlicher Arten von mehrfach
Raketenwerfern und andere Waffenarten
das ist ja alles beim Gipfel angekündigt
worden
dieser Krieg wird wie die meisten Kriege
wahrscheinlich am Verhandlungstisch
enden und wir wissen dass es eine enge
Beziehung gibt zwischen dem was man bei
Verhandlungen an Tisch erzielen kann und
der Stärke und der Position auf dem
Gefechtsfeld deshalb liegt der Ukraine
zu sagen unter welchen Bedingungen sie
das anerkennen und akzeptieren können
unter welchen Bedingungen sie also einen
Friedensabkommen unterzeichnen können
unsere Verantwortung ist es
sicherzustellen dass Sie die stärkste
Position bei den Verhandlungen bekommen
und daher müssen wir auch weiterhin
militärische Unterstützung für die
Ukraine leisten
und warum kritisieren dann so häufig die
östlichen Nato-Partner ausgerechnet
Deutschland und seine Zurückhaltung bei
der bisherigen Lieferung von schwerem
Gerät
alle Bündnispartner aber auch die
östlichen Verbündeten haben bei diesem
Gipfel eine große Unterstützung
ausgesprochen für das neue nato-modell
und darüber hinaus haben sie auch
Deutschland gelobt dafür dass
Deutschland hier wirklich auch mehr
leistet
also zeigtenbänder als Stichwort nämlich
die Entscheidung 100 Milliarden
zusätzliche Euro für die Verteidigung
zur Verfügung zu stellen und Deutschland
hat die Präsenz bereits wesentlich
erhöht
das ist in den letzten Wochen passiert
im östlichen Bereich insbesondere in
Litauen in der Nähe des Schwarzen Meeres
Deutschland hat auch wirklich der
Ukraine viel Unterstützung geboten
unsere Verbündeten sehen das auch und
sehen was Deutschland getan hat
insbesondere im Laufe der letzten Monate
nämlich das Deutschland definitiv mehr
in unsere gemeinsame Verteidigung
investiert und in die Präsenz im Osten
das zeigt ja gerade dass wir uns in
einer gefährlichen Welt befinden die
meisten Politiker und ich erinnere mich
dadurch aus an meine eigene Rolle als
Politiker
denken es ist wichtig auch in Bildung
Gesundheit in Infrastruktur zu
investieren
aber wenn die Welt gefährlicher wird
müssen wir für unsere Sicherheit sorgen
und in sie investieren und genau das tut
Deutschland
danke Jens deutenberg danke nach Madrid
heute abend danke Sommer
und damit sind wir zurück in der Runde
und haben aus Madrid ein großes Lob für
Deutschland gehört eine Einlassung wie
man sich als Politiker fühlen muss
omegnori pur ist bei uns einer der zwei
Vorsitzenden von Bündnis 90 die Grünen
15.000 Mann fanden wir da vielleicht mal
an aus Deutschland für diese schnelle
Eingreiftruppe das ist das Achtfache
300.000 Mann als der Zustand zuvor
glauben Sie dass das Deutschland
schaffen kann übernehmen wir uns da ich
zitiere ganz schnell Frau Lamprecht die
sagt wir müssen identifizieren woher die
kommen diese 15.000 können sie helfen es
ist ihre Aufgabe und ich glaube dass
wenn man bedenkt dass wir es drei Jahre
Zeit haben bis wir das erreichen und das
ist jetzt zu beginnen dass man das
hinbekommen kann ich erinnere mich sehr
wohl daran dass ich im
Verteidigungsausschuss sah sehr viele
Jahre und wir haben uns immer wieder die
Frage gestellt auch mit mit der
Generalität ob die Quote der oder die
rausgehen und rausgehen bin tatsächlich
der Gesamtsumme der Leute die dort sind
auch entspricht und ob was nicht besser
werden kann und ich glaube dass es
besser werden kann das würde bedeuten
dass man die eine oder andere
effizienzschraube auch noch mal jenseits
der Beschaffung jetzt vertreten muss so
viel Geld Deutschland als Führungsmacht
so viel Geld in die Verteidigung zu
stecken Herrn rüppur
heißt das dass wir zukünftig tatsächlich
auch unsere Ziele unsere Vorstellungen
unsere Werte militärisch durchsetzen in
der Welt wir tun schon nein wir
versuchen mit diesem Geld alles dafür zu
tun um die Hausaufgaben die
liegengeblieben sind bei der
wehrfähigkeit der Bundeswehr jetzt auf
schnellstem Wege zu begradigen damit die
Bundeswehr ihren Auftrag nach Verfassung
nämlich Bündnis und Landesverteidigung
auch ausüben kann
und gerade die bundesverteidigung ist
jetzt eine sehr sehr großes Thema es
gibt sehr viele sehr berechtigte Ängste
auch auf dem nato-gebiet im Baltikum
oder in Polen und dass wir den da jetzt
beistehen ist deshalb Verständlichkeit
Deutschland ist von Freunden umgeben
aber die Freunde nicht zwingend und das
Bündnis hat sehr viel Sicherheit auch
für Deutschland gebracht und tut es auch
weiterhin wenn man zusammen steht und
jetzt zahlen wir zurück die Amerikaner
Manfred Weber ist bei uns sehr Chef der
EVP im Europäischen Parlament herr Weber
ist uns zugeschaltet aus Dresden guten
Abend auch zu Ihnen Markus Söder der
bayerische Ministerpräsident hat und
zwei Stunden vor der Sendung aus
Termingründen abgesagt und sie sind so
freundlich und bringen einen mit all
ihre außenpolitischen Expertise
natürlich die Ergebnisse dieses Gipfels
von gestern und heute Amerikaner wieder
dauerhaft in Europa auch dauerhaft in
Deutschland und auch auf dem Gebiet des
ehemaligen Warschauer Paktes freut sie
so eine Nachricht
es freut niemanden wenn wir bewaffnen
und über Krieg reden müssen aber es
freut mich dass bei allen Gipfeln es
gibt für ein euroeuropäischen Gipfel für
G7 und auch für NATO-Gipfel ist die
Entschlossenheit deutlich geworden dass
wir zusammenstehen die schönste
Nachricht für mich ist die Aufnahme von
Schweden und Finnland in die NATO zwei
Länder die zu unserer wertefamilie
gehören Demokratien sind in Rechtsstaat
praktizieren schon heute EU-Mitglied
sind die jetzt sagen wir wollen auch zu
dieser sicherheitsfamilie gehören wir
wollen gegenseitig füreinander einstehen
und ich lass mir auch von russische
Propaganda nicht einreden dass diese
NATO-Erweiterung irgendetwas aggressives
hat sondern das ist was beschützendes
das da ausgedrückt wird durch die
Beitrittsstaaten das ist gut und richtig
und wir müssen uns im größeren
Zusammenhang klar machen wir sind heute
natürlich nicht Kriegspartei aber wir
sind Kriegsziel Putin wenn man immer mal
zuhört was er sagt er hasst unsere Art
zu leben er hasst die Freiheit er hasst
die Demokratie er hat imperiales Denken
von von vorgestern und ist die
eigentliche Herausforderung deswegen ist
die Unterstützung für die Ukraine jetzt
so notwendig und in Richtung der
Bundesregierung muss man natürlich schon
sagen ja die Entscheidungen sind jetzt
richtig und deswegen hat die
Unionsfraktion ja auch die 100
Milliarden unterstützt aber man muss
auch sagen wir sind zu Beginn des
Krieges bei 5000 Helmen gestartet und
man muss auch sagen dass noch vor einem
Jahr wie bei der Bundestagswahl
beispielsweise mit den Sozialdemokraten
darüber gestritten haben ob wir den
Drohnen die wir kaufen auch bewaffnen
sollen und dann die Sozialdemokraten
gesagt ne bewaffnen tun wir sie lieber
nicht also vor dem Punkt sind wir
gestartet insofern hat er die rot-grün
da jetzt der große Lernkurve
durchgemacht und wir sind Gott sei Dank
jetzt alle bereit in die Zukunft und
auch in die Verteidigungsfähigkeit zu
investieren was Markus Söder irgendwie
auch alles Anfang des Jahres noch gesagt
hat und im letzten Jahr vielleicht
begrüßen wir erstmal genauso herzlich in
München die nächste Gäste nämlich Nicole
deitelhoff sie ist
Politikwissenschaftlerin
friedensforscherin leitet die hessische
Stiftung Friedens und Konfliktforschung
Frau deitelhoff ist es klasse dass wir
Sie mit dabei haben wir müssen die Frage
wegen dass sich an dem eigentlichen
Balanceakt ja nichts verändert hat die
Ukraine fordert weiter mehr Waffen viel
mehr Waffen auch solche die substanziell
dieser Übermacht an militärischem Gerät
der Russen etwas entgegensetzt und auf
der anderen Seite dürfen wir nicht
Kriegspartei werden wie ist das
auszuhalten ist es überhaupt noch so
also es ist noch so wir sind ja noch
nicht Kriegspartei das ist ganz klar
aber der Balanceakt wird immer
schwieriger und er wird auch deswegen
schwieriger weil sich eben auch die
Kriegssituation verändert also sozusagen
Russland macht ja momentan systematisch
wenn auch langsamer als vielleicht
erwartet
Gebietsgewinne und sie machen das
natürlich weil sie jetzt im freien
Gelände kämpfen und dabei ihre
Artillerie Dominanz voll ausspielen
können deswegen ruft die Ukraine also
auch zu Recht nach schnelleren und mehr
schweren Gerät um dem eben etwas
entgegenzusetzen und die eigenen
Verluste auch zu bremsen wir sehen da
sehen ja das auch die Verluste der
Ukraine gestiegen sind aus Sicht
sozusagen der westlichen Staaten
bedeutet das nach wie vor aber man will
helfen und wir haben das eben ja auch
beim Generalsekretär sehr schön raus
gehört der sich zu ihrer Frage ja nicht
abschließend geäußert hat was heißt das
eigentlich was will man denn erreichen
in den Grenzen von 23 februar oder mehr
es heißt nach wie vor man muss mit
Augenmaß reagieren man tastet sich heran
und schaut wie die Gegenseite reagiert
aber im Grunde genommen ist die große
Aufgabe die jetzt ansteht zu sagen was
ist denn das gemeinsame Ziel das NATO
und Europäische Union eigentlich haben
mit Blick auf diesen Krieg und genau
darüber werden wir reden vorher stellen
wir Sabine Babs Stefanie Babs noch eine
Frage zu diesen 300.000 Mann das muss
man verstehen diese schnelle
Eingreiftruppe um das Achtfache
aufgestockt bis 2025 sollen die soll die
stehen wie und wie schnell wird die sein
und glauben sie an ihr zustande kommen
also es ist ja so dass unter dem
Oberbefehl des oder dem Kommando des
oberbefehls habe der amerikanischen
Truppen bereits schon 40.000 combat
ready also kampffähige einsatzbereite
verlegefähige Truppen existieren die
sind die Truppen die wir jetzt
gegenwärtig in Rumänien der Slowakei in
Polen und im Baltikum haben und nun
besteht die Aufgabe aus dem großen
Reservoir der Landstreitkräfte Maritim
Kräfte und Luftstreitkräfte quasi diese
NAF Pakete zu packen also der NATO
response Fonds Pakete zu packen das wird
für alle Mitgliedstaaten ein wirklich
sportliches ambitioniertes Unterfangen
sein weil diese Kräfte müssen
zertifiziert sein sie müssen geübt sein
sie müssen verlegefähig sein sie müssen
durchhaltefähig sein das heißt also ja
also sie müssen ja eine andere
rechnerische Planung vornehmen es sind
ja nicht nur sondern mal eine Brigade
von 5 großen Menschen die sie dann also
nach a schicken sie brauchen eigentlich
15.000 in der Regel werden das zahlen
die also mit drei multipliziert werden
um dann also auch die Truppen jeweils
vorzubereiten in die Übungen zu schicken
in der jeweiligen Operation dann
einzusetzen und dann werden die wieder
raus rotiert das ist wie in anderen
Operationen auch der Generalsekretär hat
ja auch angesprochen also dass die NATO
beispielsweise
Vorratshaltung für Munition und
Waffensysteme in den Alliierten Staaten
verstärken will auch das ist eine gute
Idee auf dem Papier denn es gibt
gegenwärtig beispielsweise in ganz
wenigen NATO-Staaten noch die Lager die
Hallen die Munitionsdepots die wir aus
der Zeit Munition ja also nicht die
Munition selber aber die depokus sie
müssen ja also wenn Sie mehr Munition
vorhalten wollen müssen Sie die ja
irgendwo unterbringen und das war ein
System was zur Zeit des Kalten Krieges
recht gut ausgeprägt war es wurde alles
runtergefahren und auch das müssen wir
jetzt sozusagen wieder nach oben fahren
also lange Rede kurzer Sinn es macht
Sinn aber es wird ein nicht einfach
unterwegs und welche Rolle wird die USA
in diesen in dieser Einsatztruppe
spielen und welche kann Deutschland
spielen also die USA hat ja schon
100.000 Soldaten und Soldaten in Europa
Präsident beiden hat nochmal 20.000
jetzt mit zusätzlich angekündigt damit
werden sie einen wirklich sehr sehr
starkes das größte Kontingent für diese
Kräfte mit darstellen und wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe ist Deutschland
mehr oder weniger bereit eine ja eine
Brigade Größe letztendlich auf eine
dauerhafte Zeit nicht für sechs Monate
nicht für 18 Monate dauerhaft zu
generieren und ja ich denke das wird ein
wie ich schon sagte ein nicht einfaches
Unterfangen sein allein um auf Mann und
Maus zu kommen wie die Verteidigungs
äußeren sagt wir sind mit Klaus Kleber
noch mal bei der Frage ob und wie sehr
die NATO eigentlich von den USA abhängen
Klaus und wie groß die Gefahr ist dass
diese Unterstützung der beiden Regierung
im kommenden November weniger werden
würde
zunächst mal muss man sich im Klaren
sein was diese Änderung bedeutet wir
hatten bisher von der NATO im
Mittelosteuropa vor allen Dingen im
Baltikum zum Beispiel die Tripwire
Funktionen das also
stolperträte quasi gespannt waren da
waren unter anderem diese vollen
angesprochenen 600 deutschen Soldaten im
Ball Baltikum wesentlich das ist keine
Truppe die dazu geeignet wäre die
russische Armee aufzuhalten das war eine
Truppe die da war um zu zeigen ihr
bekommt es auch mit Deutschland zu tun
wer wenn ihr etwa auf komische Ideen mit
dem Baltikum kommt das wird
grundsätzlich geändert die Truppen
sollen jetzt so verstärkt sein dass sie
in der Lage selber ähnlich wie die
ukrainischen Truppen das in ihrem Land
zur Zeit machen auch einen russischen
massiven Angriff zurückzuschlagen
natürlich müssen dann noch Verstärkungen
kommen das ist eine völlig neue Aufgabe
die Deutschland nirgendwo im Ausland
auch nicht außerhalb des nato-gebiets
auch nicht im innerhalb des
nator-gebiets bisher hatte das ist
soeben mal mit beschlossen worden ich
weiß gar nicht ob überhaupt die Reserven
da sind und Klarheit über die Größe
dieser Strategieänderung und das ist
auch in der Öffentlichkeit noch nicht so
richtig angekommen was wird die deutsche
Bevölkerung sagen wenn Sie mit den
vollen Ausmaß dieser
Reformprojekte konfrontiert wird was
wenn deutsche politische Parteien dazu
sagen zum Beispiel in einem Wahlkampf
das wird nicht populär sein
und nicht populär könnte es auch in
Amerika sein wir kommen auf Amerika
nochmal zu deinen Gedanken gerade diese
neue Strategie der NATO enthält ja auch
dass ein Angriff Russlands auf das
diesem Gebieten nicht mehr
ausgeschlossen ist logischerweise sonst
würde man sich jetzt auch nicht so
vorbereiten und versuchen sich bis unter
die Zähne zu bewaffnen was hieße das
konkret und wen könnte er als nächstes
angreifen
ja da sind vorhin die die möglichen
Adressaten alle aufgezeigt worden Moldau
und die Republik Moldau ist eine Option
georgien ist eine Option aber dann
natürlich ist das Baltikum sozusagen die
Achillesferse der NATO nur dass sie ganz
oben auf der Landkarte ist was die
Achillesferse normalerweise nicht ist
und da in der Tat ist besondere
Wachsamkeit geboten ein Angriff auf
Polen zum Beispiel erscheint im Moment
aus vielen Gründen weniger
wahrscheinlich aber natürlich hat sich
an diesem 24 Februar auch in dieser
Beziehung ein Weltbild verändert das was
man nicht denken wollte ist jetzt im
Grunde schon einmal passiert in der
Ukraine die nächste Stufe wäre eben ein
Angriff auf ein natoland und da sind
eiserne Versprechen gegeben worden ich
bin nicht sicher dass sie zum Beispiel
die deutsche Bevölkerung sich der vollen
Tragweite in den letzten 20
friedensdividenden Jahren
richtigen Zeitpunkt klar war auch das
ist politisch immer so ein bisschen
vernebelt worden und wurde angesprochen
aber sich hinzustellen und zu sagen dass
tatsächlich eine europäische
Herausforderung dieser Größenordnung
kommen könnte das ist relativ neu und
trotzdem baut die NATO-Strategie auf
dieser Festigkeit auf und Putin könnte
sich eingeladen fühlen da mal ein Test
zu machen
machen wir dazu noch mal die Runde und
fragen dann nach den USA das haben wir
nicht vergessen Herr nuripur wie groß
ist auch die
Entscheidungskraft die das diese
ampelregierung abverlangt deutlich zu
machen nochmal die Eingangsfrage ist
gestellt dass man für diese Ideale dass
man für die Ziele des Westens eben auch
militärisch einstehen muss mein Kleber
hat gesagt und ich finde er hat völlig
recht dass es jetzt sehr
außergewöhnliche Zeiten sind und dass
wir jetzt Dinge werden tun müssen die
wir so nicht vorhergesehen hatten also
wir den Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben
haben war absehbar dass die russische
Seite da jetzt einen neuen Krieg
anzetteln kann das ist halt Oktober
schon ja absehbar aber wir saßen alle da
wie in allen Staaten des Westens
schauten uns an Sachen das so doof
können sie nicht sein im Kreml und jetzt
ist das passiert und das haben wir es
nicht ausgesucht und jetzt gilt das dass
wir alles in unserer Macht stehende tun
um der Ukraine beizustehen aber auch
unsere eigene Sicherheit zu stärken und
das machen wir es muss nicht dabei
irgendwie
bequem zu gehen tut es auch nicht und
niemand fühlt sich wohl dabei ich teile
sehr was Herr Weber im ersten Satz
gesagt hat beim letzten Satz nicht mehr
aber ersten Satz hat er gesagt niemand
freut sich wenn wir jetzt über Waffen
reden es gibt keinen Grund dafür aber es
gibt eine fokussierte
Lösungsorientierung die wir alle
zusammen jetzt versuchen an den Tag zu
legen wie viel Frau Babst ist da säumt
worden und wann wären auch deutsche
Truppen deutsche Soldaten in der Lage
nato-gebiet zu verteidigen
also ich möchte zunächst einmal ein
bisschen klarstellen also die die
Kernaufgabe der NATO der kollektive
Verteidigung ist eine die ist seit 70
und plus Jahren gibt das ist keine neue
Aufgabe und ich würde auch sagen es ist
kein Strategiewechsel die Nato hat seit
2014 auch ihre
abschreckungs- und
Verteidigungsfähigkeit gegenüber
Russland ja nachhaltig und graduell
verstärkt aber sie ist dann auch ein
Stück weit auf Autopilot geblieben das
heißt es gab andere Themen es gab
Afghanistan es gab andere Operationen
Syrien und man hat dann letztendlich wie
ich finde ein ja sehenden Auges ist man
ein bisschen in diese in diese
Katastrophe gerutscht denn Präsident
Putin hat uns ja den Gefallen getan
immer wieder
verbal und schriftlich seine
strategischen Ambitionen darzulegen es
ist überhaupt keine Überraschung gewesen
dass er sich die Ukraine ausgesucht hat
und wenn man auf die Landkarte jetzt
schaut und sieht
welches Gebiet er militärisch besetzt
hat dann ist es das was er schon
2008 2009 als neurußland also da war ja
Rasierer beschrieben hat und wenn er
sich dann noch ja und wenn er sich dann
noch hinstellt und sagt er fühlte sich
in der Tradition Peters das großen und
führte Nordischen Krieg an der 21 Jahre
gedauert hat dann gibt uns das ein Clou
über seinen Zeitfenster und ich habe da
also ja also ich sie merken also ich
denke wir hätten Möglichkeiten gehabt
dass früher zu begreifen aber es ist
Vergangenheit wir müssen uns jetzt
wirklich auf die Zukunft fokussieren
über die Ukraine und diese Kriegsziele
reden wir sofort wenn wir von Klaus
Kleber noch mal diese Einschätzung zu
der Regierung von Joe Biden gehört haben
angesprochen wie fragil das Land selbst
ist auch die Situation dieser Regierung
und die NATO ist so angewiesen auf
Amerika wie wahrscheinlich nie zuvor
zunächst mal ist Joe Weiden ein
außerordentlich schwacher Präsident im
Inneren seine Umfrage und
Beliebtheitswerte die nicht unwichtig
sind sind in auf Rekord Tiefständen er
hat es nicht geschafft auch für seine
Partei eine Perspektive über sich selbst
hinaus auch nur anzudeuten es gibt
innerhalb der Demokratischen Partei im
Moment keinen Hoffnungsträger keine
Hoffnungsträgerin die Vizepräsidentin
zum Beispiel ist es sicher nicht das ist
alles so ein bisschen auf
ja taumelt in Richtung Konkurs weil auch
insgesamt eben das demokratische System
in Amerika in den letzten Jahren vor
allen Dingen von rechts
dermaßen zerrüttet worden ist dass man
nicht erst seit dem 6 Januar fürchten
muss um die Integrität des
demokratischen Modells und was das
westliche wertemodell ohne seine
Führungsmacht in Zukunft sein kann ist
natürlich eine ganz offene Frage das
bedeutet dass wir in Europa noch viel
mehr als Angela Merkel dass in ihrer
berühmten Rede in einem bayerischen
Bierzelt am Anfang der trumpzeit gesagt
hat wir müssen selber dafür sorgen dass
wir selber dastehen können das hat seit
dem 24 Februar jetzt auch eine
militärische Dimension und das was in
Madrid und vorher in Ellmau beschlossen
worden ist ist deckt sich noch nicht
oder entspricht noch nicht dieser
Herausforderung wir stehen da am Anfang
und es ist jetzt nicht die Zeit auf
Autopilot zu gehen diese Dynamik muss
weitergehen weil übrigens auch aus
russischer Sicht aus putinsicht aus
Peter des großen Sicht arbeitet die Zeit
gegen ihn das heißt wenn er in dieser
Richtung vorangehen will dann spricht
nichts dafür der NATO und dem Westen
viel Zeit zu schenken dann sind die
Bedingungen heute besser als sie
wahrscheinlich in Zukunft sein werden
wir sind bei den Kriegszielen der Westen
ist Gesicht noch nicht einig was er
eigentlich erreichen müsste
seit über vier Monaten beschwört der
Westen den Triumph über den Diktator das
Credo der Lack ist ab von Putins
Russland das ist Minimalkonsens und Kit
Russland darf diesen Krieg nicht
gewinnen die Ukraine muss bestehen
nur bestehen oder gewinnen die
demonstrative Eintracht ist fragil
Deutsche Franzosen und Italiener setzen
andere Schwerpunkte als Osteuropäer und
Angelsachsen
[Musik]
viele sagen das ist ein europäischer
Krieg der wirtschaftliche Probleme
verursacht die wir wirklich nicht
gebrauchen können
dadurch wächst der Druck auf die Ukraine
auch einen schlechten Frieden zu
akzeptieren
fast verzweifelt appelliert selensky
beim g7-treffen mehr Waffen mehr
Sanktionen um den Krieg vor dem Winter
zu beenden
schon heute halten die hochgeschraubten
westlichen Ziele der Realität auf dem
Boden der Ukraine nicht stand
[Musik]
dass die ukrainische Armee nicht in der
Lage ist dieser russischen Aggression
militärisch hinreichend zu begegnen ja
die Ukraine braucht mehr militärische
Unterstützung
Frau deitelhoff Frage nach München
beginnen wir bei ihnen
ist es vielleicht schon zu spät besteht
die Gefahr dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg
verliert
also wir haben ja vorhin schon gehört
dass man nie genau vorhersagen kann wie
ein Krieg ausgeht Kriegssituation sind
dynamisch Konflikte entwickeln sich
dynamisch und es ist sicherlich auch so
dass es leichter ist Gebiet zu
verteidigen als es zurück zu gewinnen
das heißt mit jedem Tag den die
russischen Streitkräfte Fortschritte
machen mehr Gelände einnehmen wird es
umso schwieriger für die Ukraine aber
wir haben ja immer noch keine
verlässlichen das muss man sich immer
wieder klar machen keine verlässlichen
Zahlen darüber wie es um die Verluste
bei Gerät bei den russischen Truppen wie
es um Munition Verfügbarkeit und so
weiter steht auf der russischen Seite es
kann also auch sein dass wir in vier bis
sechs Wochen erleben werden dass die
Russen massive Nachschubprobleme haben
was Gerät und Munition angeht und sich
dann das Blatt wendet wenn auch nach und
nach mehr Gerät von westlichen Staat in
der Ukraine eintrifft aber man kann es
eben nicht genau vorhersagen sondern wir
wir versuchen da eigentlich ein bisschen
von dem was wir im Feld sehen zu
extrapolieren aber das ist immer ungenau
Manfred Weber Frage zu ihnen die Kritik
aus der Union ist bekannt daran die
Ampel hätte schneller liefern sollen und
können wie groß denken sie ist die
Gefahr eine ähnliche Frage dass Putin
diesen Krieg gewinnen könnte
ja die Möglichkeit ist immer dauernd sie
hängt an unsere Unterstützung sondern
unsere unterstützungsbereitschaft wir
müssen ja die Ukraine nicht überzeugen
dass sie Krieg führen will dass sie sich
verteidigt dass Sie unsere Werte
hochhält sondern sie wollen sie will er
kämpfen sie will sich ja verteidigen das
Recht im präsidentenfrei zu wählen freie
Presse zu haben insofern geht es nur
darum lassen wir sie im Stich oder
unterstützen wir Sie und für mich kannst
du nur die Unterstützung geben mir ist
aber darüber wichtig dass wir angesichts
der Lage endlich auch wieder
vorausschauend auf die möglichen Krisen
des Herbstes schauen also das was mir im
Moment durch den Kopf geht ist das Putin
natürlich im Herbst vielleicht auch
unsere unsere Solidarität in
Energiefragen testen wird wenn wirklich
die Gaslieferungen gestoppt werden dann
droht dass wir bei der gasfrage in einer
ähnlichen nationalen Egoismus
zurückfallen wie wir es beispielsweise
bei den bei den bei der Pandemie mit dem
schengengrenzen Schließen erlebt haben
also ich meine ist dass die Gasspeicher
dann nur national genutzt werden und
trage hat letzte Woche beim Europäischen
Rat gebeten das ist jetzt Sondergipfel
gibt genau diese Frage zu klär wie gehen
wir mit der möglichen engpassung mit Gas
um ohne zurück zu fallen nationalen
Egoismus und darauf gab die Staats- und
Regierungschefs auch macron schon Olaf
Scholz keine Antwort und letzten
Gedanken zu dieser europäischen Frage
ist was Herr Kleber gesagt hat wir
bräuchten jetzt den Aufbruch endlich die
europäischen verteidigungsstrukturen
anzugehen und ich muss feststellen dass
auch dort beim europäischen Gipfel zur
Verteidigung nichts beschlossen worden
ist wir öffnen zwar die Tür für die
Ukraine also als Mitglied das ist gut
und es willkommen aber wir sind dann
nicht bereit die notwendigen nächsten
Schritte zu gehen die Vertiefung der EU
anzugehen und das ist das fehlende
Führung die Europa derzeit leider Gottes
nicht im besten Licht erscheinen lässt
wir fragen noch mal Stefanie Babs nach
der militärischen Situation jetzt kommt
nach dem alten sowjetischen Gerät eben
modernes Gerät aus dem Westen an
offensichtlich auch die Heimat und es
kommen moderne Haubitzen an die aus
Deutschland aus
Großbritannien sowieso ist das zu spät
die zu später
auf jeden Fall ist es gegenwärtig sehr
sehr viel schwieriger für die Ukraine
diese Geräte überhaupt zu dislozieren
als noch vor vier Wochen vor sechs
Wochen vor acht Wochen oder vor zehn
Wochen schlicht und ergreifend weil die
Russen natürlich auch eine relativ
effektive Aufklärung haben sie greifen
die Munitionslager an sie greifen die
Nachschubwege an sie greifen das an was
man als Loks bezeichnet also als lines
of communication sie wissen natürlich
sehr wohl über welche Wege die Waffen
geliefert werden und vor diesem
Hintergrund ist es ist es wirklich ein
echtes Unterfangen also beispielsweise
vier Haubitzen oder Panzer von A nach B
überhaupt zu bringen die Frontlinie ist
mittlerweile über 1200 km wenn wir im
ukrainischen generalstabsießen und
entscheiden sollten wo diese Geräte dann
hin sollten wo denn letztendlich eine
Verteidigung fokussiert stattfinden soll
geschweige eine Gegenoffensive ist das
wirklich sehr sehr schwer also das ist
das eine und das andere ist ich würde
mich überhaupt nicht darauf verlassen
das ist natürlich auch der russischen
militärischen Seite Defizite und
Schwierigkeiten gibt die Russen nutzen
Artillerie ja das nutzt sich ab aber sie
nutzen noch verstärkter Cruise Missile
und andere raketenarten und feuern jeden
Tag zwischen 25 und 30 Raketen aus dem
Schwarzen Meer dem Kaspischen Meer und
auch aus Weißrussland auf ukrainische
Städte ich fürchte wir werden davon mehr
sehen in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
und ich fürchte Zerstörung noch mehr
Zerstörung auf auf pulverisierungen
Pulverisierung und dann bleibt immer
noch die für die Ukraine natürlich
absolut lebenswichtige Frage wie können
sie Odessa verteidigen das ist der
letzte wenn Sie so wollen freie Hafen
wenn auch vermiet und blockiert aber das
ist für sie wirtschaftlich absolut
überlebenswichtig und ich gehe davon aus
dass sich Herr Putin die Perle aus mit
dem Schwarzen Meer oder des Schwarzen
Meeres holen wird
und deshalb ist das Stichwort Frage an
Frau deitelhoff wir nehmen den Gedanken
von Manfred Weber noch mal auf kann
unsere kann die Unterstützung des
Westens nachlassen wenn auch unsere
innenpolitischen sorgen wachsen wenn wir
Angst um Energie und um einen eine warme
Heizung haben ja absolut natürlich also
wenn sich die Zustimmung der Bevölkerung
zu Sanktionen zu militärischer
Unterstützung der Ukraine dreht also
wenn wir sehen dass eine große Mehrheit
der Bevölkerung gegen ein Weiterführen
der Sanktionen und ein Weiterführen der
militärischen Unterstützung ist dann
wird es eben auch für eine Regierung
sehr schwierig dieses Engagement
aufrecht zu erhalten darum ist es so
wichtig wir haben das letzte Woche auch
in unserem friedensgutachten das einmal
jährlich erscheint gesagt dass man
frühzeitig die Kosten dieser Sanktionen
immer wieder öffentlich thematisiert und
dass man frühzeitig klug politisch
steuert so dass eben diejenigen die auch
mehr Lasten tragen können diese tragen
und diejenigen die das nicht können auch
belastet werden also es geht nicht um
den kollektiven Tankrabatt oder den
kollektiven Gas Rabatt sondern es geht
darum tatsächlich politisch klug zu
steuern damit diejenigen die es können
auch mehr beitragen und da sind wir bei
den Grünen Herrn noripur welche Rolle
werden sie in dieser Hinsicht in der
ampelregierung spielen müssen sie auch
da die FDP und die Sozialdemokraten
treiben und sie davon überzeugen
möglichst wahnsinnig transparent sehr
klar anzukündigen welche hatten Monate
auf die deutschen zukommen alle wissen
wie groß die Aufgabe ist wir brauchen
einander nicht zu treiben alle sehen wie
gewaltig auch die Aufgaben sein können
und werden Richtung Winter es ist kein
Naturgesetz dass das so kommt und wir
arbeiten alle mit Hochdruck dran damit
die Energiesicherheit auch gewährleistet
ist beispielsweise vor allem
Wärmebereich da gibt es die größten und
Sicherheiten weil wir auch nicht wissen
ob Putin die Gashähne von seiner Seite
aus
dazu dreht niemand kann das ausschließen
und wir haben bisher zwei große
entlassungspakete beschlossen im Sinne
dessen was Frau dattelhof gerade
beschrieben hat und es werden auch
weitere folgen müssen und wir werden
sehr genau miteinander angucken wohin
die Belastung gerade hingeht es ist
völlig richtig was Sie gesagt haben und
was Frau dattlauf auch gesagt hat diese
Belastung haben in erster Linie was mit
Energiepreisen zu tun die Energiepreise
haben mit dem Krieg Putin sehr sehr viel
zu tun und Putin will das so putin will
dass die Solidarität hier bricht will
dass die Geduld unserer Öffentlichkeit
nach die Probe gestellt wird und deshalb
ist es notwendig sehr klar und deutlich
zu sagen Leute es wird schwer wir tun
alles damit es aushaltbar ist und bleibt
und wir trotzdem sehr schwer und wir
werden da zusammen stehen müssen es geht
um nicht weniger als um Demokratie in
Europa und was wenn nun sogar beides
zusammenkommt eine offensichtlich sehr
massive und ja fast asymmetrische
asymmetrische Überlegenheit der Russen
am Boden und der auf uns zukommende
herbst- und Winter mit genau dieser
Aussicht das nicht nur die Preise für
sämtliche Lebensmittel steigen sondern
auch die Energiepreise und die
Heizkosten das sind gleich zwei
schlechte Nachrichten wo man natürlich
auch Abwinken kann und sagen kann lass
uns doch besser aufhören und zwar
schlechte Nachrichten es ist absehbar
das Putin jetzt noch mehr Getreide und
den ernährungsweltmarkt als Waffen nutzt
und gleichzeitig beispielsweise
afrikanischen Staaten zu sagen ich will
euch ja ernähren aber die Sanktionen
lassen mich das nicht in der böse Westen
ist es die haben euch vor 100 Jahren
kolonialisiert also müsst ihr doch
wissen dass ich recht habe es gibt sehr
viele solche Nachrichten zurzeit aber es
ist erstens auch keine Option aufzugeben
es geht hier wirklich um alles es ist
gesagt worden es geht hier um unseren
Lebensstil es geht um unsere Freiheiten
und zweitens arbeiten wir mit Hochdruck
an Lösungen aller Art es hat Robert
Habeck sich nicht träumen lassen dass in
einer Katha fahren muss um Gas zu kaufen
er macht das und im Prinzip etliche
Beispiele solche Art dass wir einfach
versuchen so schnell wie möglich die
Probleme anzugehen die gerade auf dem
Tisch sind Manfred Weber ist in unserer
letzten Sendung gestanden und hat gesagt
wenn Kiel fällt wird die Welt auch
Deutschland eine Mitschuld daran geben
dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg verloren
haben
das ist ein stimmender Befund hätten wir
das Möglichste hätten wir alles tun
können wir
haben ich muss mir immer wieder die
Augen reiben wenn gerade herr Weber für
die 5000 Helme beispielsweise hier
anspricht weil die
die Bestände der Bundeswehr einfach
beschämend klein waren und ist immer
noch sind und wir versuchen ja mit
großem Nachdruck das zu verändern und da
gab es Leute die dafür verantwortlich
waren die auch bestens kennt in den
letzten 16 Jahren aber erstens habe ich
Herrn Stoltenberg und auch viele andere
aus Europa ganz anders gehört und
zweitens Kiew wird nicht fallen und wir
sollten auch dem nicht das Wort reden
wir sondern wir sollten alles dafür tun
die ukraineren Ukraine gewinnen und
gewinnen heißt dass sie ihre Freiheit
ihre Souveränität ihre Würde
zurückerlangen können das wird ein ganz
ganz langer Kampf sein auch wenn die
Waffen schweigen ist alles nur nicht
Frieden eingekehrt wir werden nicht
anerkennen können auch nur ein
Quadratzentimeter annektierten Boden
durch Russland und die
Auseinandersetzung mit Russland in
dieser Frage die die drohende und dann
anstehende komplette Entkopplung
wirtschaftlich die ganzen Proxies die
ganzen Stellvertreter Kriege die die
Russland führen kann von Mali über
Syrien über Libyen das ist alles extrem
viel und gewaltig und wir stehen am
Anfang eines Marathons
Klaus Kleber die
formuliert die optimistisch formulierten
Kriegs Ziele wir haben ja von manchen
Gästen hier gehört die Ukraine muss die
Krim zurückholen sie werden nicht nur
diese besetzen Gebiete zurückholen
sondern sie werden auch die Krim
zurückholen
können auch zu optimistische Kriegsziele
die Kraft die Solidarität des
Durchhaltevermögen eines Landes negativ
beeinflussen
zu optimistische nicht aber
utopische doch
es ist es findet ja ein allgemeiner
Eiertanz um diese Kriegsziele im Moment
statt niemand erklärt offiziell dass die
der Rückzug der Russen aus aus Krim von
der Halbinsel Krim unbedingt das
Ergebnis dieses Krieges sein muss und
weil sich niemand genau in die
abgrenzungsgebiete dieser dieser
Forderungen begeben will der politisch
Verantwortung trägt ist das etwas was im
für Jeton stattfindet wenn ich
persönlich mir vorstelle und dann auch
die Parallelen ziehe zum Kalten Krieg
dann geht kein Weg am Ende daran vorbei
dass man eine Lösung findet die beide
Seiten im Moment im Ruhe lassen die man
nicht anerkennt aber doch akzeptiert im
Zweifel wird die russische Kontrolle
über die Krim dann dazugehören mein Gott
wir haben im Kalten Krieg lange Zeit
zwei deutsche Staaten gehabt von denen
der eine den anderen nicht anerkannt hat
jedenfalls nicht als einziges
Deutschland und trotzdem hat man dann
irgendwie ein Benehmen gefunden sogar
eine annäherungspolitik wieder zu
formulieren irgendwann das ist im Moment
noch weit weg solange dort ein heißer
Krieg kämpft aber es wird eine Lösung
geben müssen die nicht der völliger
Rückzug der der russischen Armee aus
jedem ukrainischen Quadratkilometern
sein kann aber sicher auch nicht auf die
Dauer in akzeptiertes Beherrschen von
20% des ukrainischen Staatsgebietes wie
jetzt mit der netzkonflug ganz im Osten
der Ukraine irgendwo dort wird eine
Lösung zu suchen sein wenn dann die
diplomatische Phase beginnt aber die
sehe ich in den nächsten Wochen noch
nicht kommen noch nicht kommen und auch
wenn Jens deutenberg das vorhin
zurückgewiesen hat die Kritik der
Osteuropäer gerade an Ländern wie
Frankreich Italien und Deutschland die
war ja nicht nur leise oder nur im Ton
zu lesen die wünschen sich zusammen mit
Boris Johnson einen viel effizienteren
und einen viel härteren Umgang mit
Russland bei den Franzosen wie gesagt
sieht das ein bisschen anders aus wo
stehen heute die USA auch
beiden blinken Leute Osten sind
verschiedentlich zu zitieren das Ziel
der USA in diesem Krieg ist welches das
Ziel der USA ist zu einer Lösung zu
kommen mit der die Ukraine als
unabhängiger souveränerstaat lebensfähig
ist und Einhalt zu gebieten gegenüber
dem was möglicherweise der neue Peter
der Große in Europa und übrigens auch in
Südosteuropa und bis hinein nach kleinen
Asien für Ziele verfolgt das muss
gestoppt werden das wird aber am Ende
nicht das Ergebnis sein können dass das
Russland komplett scheitert das wäre ein
eine totales militärisches Desaster was
übrigens nicht abgeschlossen ist aber es
ist kein Ziel dafür dass man sich
festlegen könnte dazu wissen wir einfach
zu wenig über die innere Verfasstheit
der russischen Streitkräfte ihre
Nachfolge ihrer Nachschubprobleme und so
weiter das Bild ist sehr verworren im
Moment in dieser Hinsicht Frau
deitelhoffnickt Frage an man